[Music]
agent
let's get you up to speed on what you'll
be dealing with out there we need you to
recover critical data from shade tech
stations that got left behind in the
dark zone before rogue agents can
intercept it you'll have to capture all
three stations at each objective to
start uploading data you can enable
turret and pulse fortifications at
certain objectives to help defend them
activating them requires shade tech that
you can recover from enemies and finding
crates in the dark zone oh and another
thing be aware of the two tactical
boosts you can use to enhance your
squads performance points for kills and
point multiplier you can activate these
with shade tech as well remember that
you're part of a squad and everybody has
a role collecting shade tech to powerup
tactical boosts or fortifications can be
just as important as securing objectives
teamwork is the key to winning this
fight I need the whole file before I can
decrypt it so make sure we get to 100%
before the enemy does good hunting
you